close your eyes for a moment will you
please
and breathe with me just close your eyes
and if you will
put your thumb
to your middle finger
and gather your other fingers around and
let's feel the vibration
and pulse of your personal energy as you
take three deep breaths with me
inhale
and as you exhale just feel
the vibration
energy
blood
pulsating
through
your body through you
and another inhale
and another inhale
ah
and keep your eyes closed
and let's just think about
this day
this day that you have been graced
to breathe
in and out
thousands of times
this day
where many of those breaths were taken
for granted you just expected the next
one to come
but the truth is there's no guarantee
that the next one comes
this day
how you started your day what your
thoughts were this morning
how you've carried yourself through this
day
how you've been allowed to have
encounters and experiences
some challenging
some more life enhancing
that push you forward another day
of being here on the planet earth
as a human
being
let's just think about that
after all you've been through
in this day alone
and the many days and years passed
how you got here to this
prestigious esteemed university
the choices you made
that have brought you to this day
open your heart
and quietly to yourself
say the only prayer
that's ever needed
thank you
thank you
thank you
you're still here
and you get another chance
this day
to do better and be better
another chance to become more
of who
you were created
and what you were created to fulfill
thank you that's how it starts
that is the foundation
for
meaning and purpose in your life
is to bring yourself
back to your breath
in all situations and all ways and all
challenges to know that the value of
just still
being
here
matters it's really big that you're here
it's really big
because everybody here has been called
from the ethers
to do the will
to fulfill the highest expression of
yourself
as a human being
and to do that in truth
how do you do that
well i think you let every
step you take move you in the direction
of the one thing all religions can agree
on and that is love there's really only
two emotions that count
and that's love and that's fear
and in all of your
movements through life
you're either moving in the direction of
one or the other
in order to have a meaningful life
you have to choose love
and not the schmaltzy dalty kind of love
but the kind of love
that really counts
the kind of love that when everything
else is going wrong and nobody even
knows you're choosing it you choose love
the kind of love that says i'm here for
you no matter what you choose love the
kind of love that means you make the
right decision
even when you know the other person is
wrong
you choose love because
love
is not just
um it's an it's it's a verb
and it's everything that represents
kindness
and grace
and harmony and cooperation
and reverence for life
so when you choose in the direct when
you have you're in a situation where you
are mad you are mad and you know
they are wrong
if you can go to that space
of the breath
in god i move and breathe and have my
being
and make the choice just to move a
little closer in the direction of that
which is going to bring you grace
that which is going to honor yourself
and by honoring yourself you can't help
but honor the other person
i have learned to choose love
over fear
to choose love
and peace
rather than choosing to be right
that was a big lesson for me every
single
thought we have or every sentence we
speak is an affirmation
and it's either positive or negative and
it's going out from us and it's creating
our experiences
however when we talk about doing
affirmations what we're talking about
is
making
definite positive statements to create
something in our life or to remove
something in our life you see if you
stand there and say i don't want this
job or i don't want this relationship or
i don't want these hips or i don't want
whatever that does not get you what you
want
that's what i call fighting the negative
and it doesn't do anything but keep what
you have that you say you don't want
however if you start saying and doing
affirmations that i have a wonderful new
job
or i have this most absolutely marvelous
relationship then you're beginning to
create what it is you do want
affirmations are like planting seeds
and if you think for a moment when you
put a seed in the ground you do not get
instant tomato plant or instant
strawberries or instant oak tree
that seed goes in the ground and it has
to germinate
that's the first thing which means it
breaks open its little shell and little
roots begin to go down
and it gets nourishment from the earth
and only then
does the first little shoot come up
through the ground
now when we're doing affirmations too
often people say well that isn't a
million dollars and they stomp on that
first little chute
they don't give it a chance to grow
[Laughter]
doing affirmations is like planting a
seed in the ground and watering is it it
is like repeating your affirmations and
you just keep doing them and you keep
doing them and you keep doing them and
it doesn't matter whether you see the
results or you don't see the results and
sometimes it just takes time and too
many people will do affirmations for two
or three days and say see it doesn't
work
you know
if
everything happens in the perfect time
space sequence and we want to trust that
and we want to know that so if you begin
to do affirmations for yourself
and i think it's important that we do
that on a daily basis decide what you
want
and begin to do positive statements in
present tense for what you want you
never want to say i will have or i'm
going to have because if you do that it
keeps it in the future
and remember
if you say i have a wonderful new
apartment and you're living in a dump it
doesn't mean that this is not a true
statement it means you are planting the
seed that will germinate and grow and
become the new apartment so you just
keep doing it no matter what where you
are also if you're leaving a situation
if you're in a job you don't like if
you're in a relationship you don't like
if you're in a a house you don't like
and you want something new begin to
bless with love
interesting
bless with love
where you are
and and know that you're releasing your
current situation with love if it's a
job release it with love to the next
person who will be delighted to have it
if it's an apartment do the same thing
if it's a relationship release that
person with love to happiness which is
meaningful to them
and that leaves you free to create and
accept happiness that is meaningful to
you
we can refuse to think certain thoughts
look how often you have refused to think
a positive thought about yourself
well
you can also refuse to think a negative
thought about yourself too
it seems to me that everyone on this
planet that i know
or have worked with
is suffering from self-hatred and guilt
to one degree or another the more
self-hatred and guilt we have the less
our life works
we find we have an inability to speak up
for ourselves and we are always trying
to please others
or we may be angry and explosive all the
time
the less self-hatred and guilt we have
the better our lives work on all levels
this includes the health of the body too
it has been my experience that the very
bottom line for everyone i have worked
with is always
i'm not good enough
and we often add to this i don't do
enough
or
i don't deserve
does this sound like you
always saying or implying or feeling
that you are not good enough
but for whom
and according to whose standards
now if these negative beliefs are very
strong in you
then how can you possibly create a
loving joyous prosperous healthy life
somehow your subconscious beliefs would
always be contradicting these objectives
and making sure you do not obtain your
goals
i find that resentment criticism guilt
and fear
cause more problems in our bodies and in
our experiences than anything else
these feelings come from blaming others
and not taking responsibility
for our own lives
you see if we are all one hundred
percent responsible for everything in
our lives
then there is no one to blame
whatever is happening out there
is only a mirror of our own inner
thinking
i am not condoning other people's poor
behavior
but we must realize it is our beliefs
that attract to us
people that will treat us that way
if you find yourself saying everyone
always does such and such to me
criticizes me ignores me takes advantage
of me or abuses me
then this is your pattern
there is some thought in you that
attracts this behavior
on some internal level you believe you
deserve to be treated this way
or
you treat other people this way and it
is just coming back to you
whatever we give out mental physical or
verbal will come back to us
when we no longer think or behave this
way
the other people will change their
behavior
or they will go and do that to someone
else who believes they deserve it
you will no longer be attracting the
experiences you say you do not want
whether we want to change a life
experience or a physical problem the
place to begin is to say so
literally say
i am willing to release the pattern
within me
that is creating this experience or this
condition
you can say this to yourself over and
over every time you think of your
illness
say this with me now
i am willing to release the pattern in
me
that has created this condition
the minute you say this affirmation you
are stepping out of the victim role
you are no longer helpless
you are acknowledging your own power
you are saying
i may not understand it
but somehow i am beginning to understand
that i contributed to creating this
problem and now i take my own power back
and i
am releasing it and letting it go
what a powerful statement to have your
subconscious mind supporting
as i said resentment of others criticism
of ourselves
guilt over the past and fear of the
future are the most damaging mental
thought patterns we can have
this kind of internal dialogue creates
and maintains dis-ease in the body
these thoughts can destroy the body
fear can contribute to baldness
ulcers
colon problems and even painful feet
among other things
criticism as a permanent habit can often
lead to arthritis in the body
resentment long held
eats away at the body and becomes the
dis-ease we call cancer
guilt always looks for punishment and
creates pain
when you uh want to override automatic
negative thoughts or disempowering you
know beliefs uh or self-image issues the
first thing you want to do from a brain
perspective
is first
acknowledge that hey i have this
disempowering thought or disempowering
image a self-image for disempowering
fear i acknowledge that that's okay so
the first thing you do is you don't
pretend it doesn't exist because your
brain knows it exists you notice that
the dog knows it exists
but when you take that
and say yes that's true and now i'm
going to create a new vision for what i
want
to feel i'm going to create a new vision
for how i want to see myself i'm going
to create a new vision to
see myself at the level
above the level that i'm at right now
and you create an image and write it
down
and then what you can do is you can
create a new powerful declaration or
affirmation that goes like this you may
want to write this down okay and that's
just the beginning process of retraining
your brain there's there's six different
steps that you can do here i'll give you
two of them so you create a declaration
and you say
even though
i feel or even though i have this belief
of
what i
am focusing on now
is
my augmented self-worth or self-esteem
what i'm focusing on now is getting
smarter wiser what i'm focusing on now
is releasing this fear and stepping into
my confidence and my certainty now a
simple
little declaration of acceptance and
then moving towards what you want
that starts to activate a new neural
pattern so you don't have to lie to
yourself and say you know
for example is if you feel like you're
not smart enough not worthy
not capable and you say you know in the
past i have felt that i wasn't smart
enough not worthy not capable and now
i'm learning how to
if you could just create a bridge from
the disempowering thought or belief or
emotion or behavior
and you can create a bridge to where the
next step is and now i'm learning how to
and now i'm taking steps towards
when you give yourself that bridge your
brain goes okay you can do this
so if you don't want to go from i'm not
smart enough to i'm really smart and i
could achieve it for some people that's
too big of a jump so create a bridge
between those two
so that you reduce the neural tension
and you're nice to your brain and that
is one of the ways that you can do that
just see love
just see possibility
just see all the things that you've come
through
and then i want you to speak to yourself
as if you were your best friend say your
first name i would say lisa say your
first name and then complete these three
sentences the first sentence
say your name first
lisa i would say lisa
i'm proud that you and find seven
different things to celebrate yourself
for and they can be small things lisa
i'm proud that you got out of bed this
morning i'm proud that you
i'm proud that you pray today
i'm proud that you went to work today
i'm proud that you set a healthy
boundary in that relationship i'm proud
that you got out of the relationship i'm
proud that you said yes even though
you're afraid
to leap about that new job i'm proud
that you
got on the phone today with your mother
whatever that small thing is that you
can celebrate they don't have to be big
huge things remember celebrate the micro
wins and the micro wins become macro
wins and you say i forgive you for
go back 20 years go back 10 years
go back five years or go back five days
lisa i forgive you for getting in a
relationship
that wasn't worthy of you
lisa i forgive you for lowering your
integrity bar and saying yes when you
really should have said no
lisa i forgive you for endangering
jaylani when you got into an abusive
relationship unknowingly
lisa i forgive you for not getting out
sooner quicker faster
lisa i forgive you for gaining over 80
pounds
being too stubborn to go to the doctor
to find out what was really wrong
at least i forgive you for blaming
yourself
when a relationship didn't go right
and he left
when in fact man's rejection
was really god's protection
but you blamed you
that second sentence
is liberating
sobering
a little painful
and definitely free lisa i commit to you
that today i will only say yes when i
want to say yes
and i'll say no on the days that i need
to say no
lisa i commit to you that i won't keep
score i won't collect evidence on why
life won't work for you our
relationships won't work for you or this
next eating plan won't work for you
i won't keep track i mean i won't keep
score i won't collect evidence why it
won't work i'll keep track on why it
should work
lisa i commit to you
that today
i'll stop the negative chatter sooner
quicker faster research study and
psychology found out that both second
person and third person makes you more
it makes yourself talk more powerful so
if you're gonna do affirmations you
wouldn't just say i wanna do this i
wanna do this you wanna do what we call
in the book self-coaching where you
would say you know in my case yeah
brendan it's important you do a good job
here today because you usually don't do
interviews and you really love marie and
you want to do a good job for her and
her people
and this is a book you worked on for
three years and it's important it does
well and brendan don't forget
you're so lucky you get to do this
brother so just enjoy the process you're
so lucky brendan
that's a different level of going i'm
lucky i'm lucky right
it is i'm brendan yes yes another one
another one i do every morning yeah
assuming i take a shower but every
morning in the shower because we all
don't every day not every morning no we
do not this doesn't happen it does not
happen i told you like 24 hours ago i
was staying in a barn in the woods at a
friend's house
but the second thing i ask myself in the
in the shower every morning is
what might happen today that could trip
me up
and how are you going to bring your best
self to that brendan
i say that every morning in the shower
to myself and it just helps me
anticipate that you know something's
going to go wrong during the day
absolutely and if i already know
everything like like this morning's was
okay
you're in
i think what we would i think i'm yes
north manhattan where i'm staying would
you call it north you're uptown i'm
uptown and you're coming to um let's
just call it downtown okay so i'm like
okay that's gonna be
45 minutes it's a hot summer day yes
i'm gonna get hot and i know when i'm
hot sometimes i get impatient yes and i
get stressed and i don't want to feel
that so just pay attention to how you're
feeling on your way down to the
interview with marie brendan
and really just engage pay attention be
present with new york and really enjoy
that you're here i know that sounds
completely crazy but every high
performing athlete does it every
salesperson does it i mean at high level
every person i interviewed who are at
what we call the top 15 of all high
performers
they all self-talk and most of them we
found we're doing it in second and third
person
which is amazing i love it yeah i think
it's so fun yeah little things yeah so
if you already talk to yourself and you
say your name to yourself
they're not crazy you're probably high
performing a few weeks ago during a
company meeting someone asked for some
ideas to break a late night cookies and
ice cream habit this person said and i
quote it's like i turn into a child at
9pm and i have to have my cookies and my
ice cream before bed this needs to stop
and i mean i could relate i don't think
that there is any human on the planet
who at any given time doesn't have at
least one habit that really needs to get
kicked to the curb
well it turns out that there's a simple
two-word fix that can dramatically
increase our ability to resist
temptation and it gives us a better
chance to make a better choice now this
is based on research done by dr vanessa
patrick she's a professor of marketing
at the university of houston who
published her findings on the power of
self-talk in the journal of consumer
research
she found that when participants framed
a refusal as i don't for instance i
don't eat chocolate cake or i don't eat
sugar instead of i can't they were more
successful at resisting the desire to
eat unhealthy foods or skip the gym
in fact they found that when it came to
deciding whether to eat certain foods
saying i don't was nearly three times as
effective as saying no and about eight
times more effective than saying i can't
very interesting right
i don't versus i can't two teeny tiny
words that can make a ginormous
difference and here's why when we say i
don't we are empowered we're determined
we are at choice it's a tough strong
phrase like end of story but when we say
i can't we disempower ourselves it
sounds like we're not allowed to do
something by some outside force you know
what we make ourselves feel deprived
when we say i can't and in essence we
make ourselves weak whiny little [ __ ]
like
i can't have a cookie
now what's even cooler though is that we
can tuck this little trick into every
corner of our lives we can start making
some clear strong declarations like this
i don't eat skinny pop i
am
balanced i express
balance
repeat these words out loud with
conviction
with certainty
with confidence with passion and with
power in your voice i
am
balance
i have balance
i am love
i have
love
i am motivated
to pursue
the life of my dreams
i am powerful
beyond belief
keep repeating these words you can say
them over
and over again
i
am enough
i have always been enough
i will always be enough
i am enough
and i always will be enough
i am lovable
i am worthy of love
and again i am lovable
i
am worthy of love
i am so in balance
that i give love
and i receive love
the more love i give
the more love i receive
because i am balance
i give and receive
love
i give
and receive praise
specially
to myself
i give
and receive compliments
i grow
my own self-esteem with love
praise
and compliments
i am
self-directed
i am purposeful
i
am productive
i am blessed
i am grateful
i am
worthy
i am healthy
i am intuitive
i am smart
i am beautiful inside
and out
i am magnetically
attractive
i am brave
i am lovable
i am successful
i am warm
i am empathic
i am deeply
deeply lovable
just the way i am
i am peaceful
i am full of respect
for myself and others
i am self-respecting
i am evolved
i am sorted
i am balanced
i am equal to everyone
i am flexible
i am open
i am present
i am a person that
matters i am deeply
significant
i am talented
i am gifted
i am
inspirational
i am positive
i am healthy
i have a generous heart
a generous nature
i give
and i receive
i am wonderful
i am gorgeous
i am so beautiful
i have a beautiful soul
a beautiful heart
a beautiful nature
i am a gorgeous person
i am curious
i'm always learning
i am grateful
for my life
i started to pay very careful attention
to what i was saying
i don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but i could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and the split and i've actually
had students tell me the same thing has
happened to them
after they've
listened to some of the material that
that i've been describing to all of you
but
i split into two
let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me that was talking a lot
and that
liked to argue and that liked ideas and
there was another part that was watching
that part like just with its eyes open
and neutrally judging
and the part that was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going
that isn't your idea
you don't really believe that
you don't really know what you're
talking about
that isn't true and i thought that's
really interesting so now and that was
happening to like 95 of what i was
saying and so then i didn't really know
what to do i thought okay this is
strange so maybe i've fragmented and
that's just not a good thing at all i
mean it wasn't like i was hearing voices
or anything like that i mean it wasn't
like that
it was it was well people have multiple
parts
so then i had a this weird conundrum is
like well which of these two things are
me
is it the part that's listening and
saying no that's
rubbish that's a lie that's
you're doing that to impress people
you're just trying to win the argument
you know
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal verbal business me
and i didn't know but i decided i would
go with the critic and then what i'd
tried to do what i learned to do i think
was to stop saying things that made me
weak
and now that i mean i'm still trying to
do that because i'm always
feeling when i talk
whether or not the words that i'm saying
are either making me align or making me
come apart
and i think the alignment i really do
think the alignment is i think alignment
is the right way of conceptualizing it
because i think if you say things that
are
as true as you can say them let's say
then they come up
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from we don't know how far down
into your substructure the thoughts
emerge we don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being we don't understand any of that we
don't even conceptualize that but i
believe that you can feel that and i
learned some of that from reading carl
rogers by the way who's a great
clinician
because he talked about mental health in
part as a coherence between the
the
the spiritual or the or the abstract and
the physical that the two things were
aligned and and there's a lot of idea of
alignment in in psychoanalytic and
clinical thinking
but anyways i decided that i would start
practicing not saying things that would
make me weak and what happened was that
i had to stop saying almost everything
that i was saying i would say 95 of it
as a hell of a shock to wake up and i
mean this was over a few months but it's
a hell of a shock to wake up and realize
that you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock
you know and you might think well do you
really want all of that to burn off it's
like well there's nothing left but a
little husk five percent of you it's
like well if that five percent is
solid
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen i want to start with two
questions that i really want you to
think about
and the two questions are
what should i be afraid of today
and who's to blame
[Music]
what should scare me and whose fault is
it
to me
these are the most
profoundly dangerous
questions that we center our lives
around
um
and what they are indicators
to me with their indicators of is a
culture of scarcity
a culture of not enough
and when you think about think about any
milieu in your life think about
education
what are we supposed to be afraid of
and who's to blame
politics the economy social issues
i guarantee you if you turn on the news
or open to paper today the focus would
be
here's why you should be afraid and
here's whose fault it is
and it
and what's interesting to me about that
is it's not just at a cultural level or
a community level that stuff happens in
my house every week
every week with my husband
i talk to him about what we should what
should be you know why we should be
fearful and whose fault it is mostly
it's his
um
but you know if something doesn't go
well at my daughter's school
then i'm like oh my god
this is this is going to have huge
implications for university
and we should be terrified right now
that she's not getting cursive i know
she's four
but this is still relevant
it's indicative of scarcity so let's
talk about what scarcity culture is
and what it looks like scarcity culture
i think is best understood with a simple
question of
never enough
and you can fill in the blanks
never good enough safe enough certain
enough perfect enough
relevant enough and perhaps i think one
of the most dangerous and insidious
messages today
is never extraordinary enough
somehow
in the world we live in today
an ordinary life has become synonymous
with a meaningless life
um and it has huge i mean and i've
watched it happen not only as a
researcher i'm a qualitative researcher
so i sit across from people and look in
their eyes and i have a good sense of
what's going on in their lives but as a
university professor who's been teaching
for the last 17 years
it's been very clear to me that
extraordinary means relevant
and the top one is is the big one for
all of us personally never good enough
you know which is shame
which we all have
on occasion that sense
that we're not smart enough good enough
perfectly enough loved enough promoted
enough
we're not enough
so what we do in response to scarcity
culture i think all of us every day
is this
we wake up in the morning and we armor
up
and we we put it on and we say i'm going
to go out in the world
i'm basically just going to kick some
ass
i'm not going to let anyone see who i am
and in doing so i can protect myself
against the things that hurt the most
judgment criticism fear blame ridicule
i'm gonna armor up and i'm gonna be safe
and we rationalize and we convince
ourselves that this armor is really
smart
and we use a lot of different things to
armor too
perfectionism
intellectualizing
but if you get really really clear about
what we're doing every morning when we
wake up and decide to armor
it's this simple
this is what we're protecting
we're protecting
[Music]
being hurt
for a very simple reason
that no one really wants to talk about
which is this
love
belonging
irreducible needs of men women and
children
in the absence of love and belonging
there is always suffering and so what we
believe is that we can protect our sense
of being lovable
and being acceptable and being worth
connection
with armor
here's the very worst news from my
research
the news that above all other i did not
want to hear
is simply this and i don't even want to
say it to you because i think it's mean
to say it
but it's so true
and it's simply
our capacity
for wholeheartedness
can never be greater than our
willingness to be brokenhearted
which is a terrible thing
but a truthful thing
that we can only love and be loved
as much as we are willing to have our
heart broken
and so when we move to the world like
this
and with our partners with our children
with our friends in classrooms with the
people who work for us with the people
we work for
there are tremendous casualties
newtonian world is all about the
predictable it's all about predicting a
future but the quantum model of reality
is is about causing an effect the moment
you start feeling abundant and worthy
you are generating wealth the moment
you're empowered and feel it you're
beginning to step towards your success
the moment you start feeling whole
your healing begins and when you love
yourself and you love all of life you'll
create an equal and now you're causing
an effect
and i think that's the the difference
between living as a victim
in your world saying i am this way
because of this person or that thing or
this experience they made me think and
feel this way
when you switch that around you become a
creator of your world and you start
saying my thinking and my feeling is
changing an outcome in my life and now
that's a whole different game and we
start believing more that we're creators
of reality how do we then go from that
like mechanistically
to begin this visualization process of
something that's empowering it's me in a
different state it's my future self is
it meditation is it
what does that look like if you're not
being defined by a vision of the future
then you're left with the old memories
of the past and you will be predictable
in your life
and if you wake up in the morning and
you're not being defined by a vision in
the future as you see the same people
and you go to the same places and you do
the exact same thing at the exact same
time
it's no longer that your personality is
creating your personal reality now your
personal reality is affecting or
creating your personality your
environment is really controlling how
you think and feel unconsciously because
every person everything every place
every experience has a neurological
network in your brain
every experience that you have with
every person produces an emotion so some
people will use their boss to reaffirm
their addiction to judgment they'll use
their enemy to reaffirm their addiction
to hatred they'll use their friends to
reaffirm their addiction to suffering so
now they need the outer world to feel
something
so
to change then
is to be greater than your environment
to be greater than the conditions in
your world and the environment is that
seductive
so then
why is meditation the tool well
let's sit down let's close our eyes
let's disconnect
from your outer environment so if you're
seeing less things there's less
stimulation going to your brain if
you're playing soft music or you have
ear plugs in less sensory information
coming to your brain so you're
disconnecting from your environment if
you can sit your body down
and tell it to stay like an animal stay
right here i'm going to feed you when
we're done you can get up and check your
emails you can do all your texts but
right now you're going to sit there and
obey me
so then
when you do that properly and you're not
eating anything or smelling anything or
tasting anything you're not up
experiencing and feeling anything
you would have to agree with me that
you're being defined by a thought right
so when the body wants to go back to its
emotional past
and you become aware that your attention
is on that emotion and where you place
your attention is where you place your
energy
you're siphoning your energy out of the
present moment into the past and you
become aware of that
and you settle your body back down in
the present moment because it's saying
well it's 8 o'clock you normally get
upset because you're in traffic around
this time and here you are sitting and
we're used to feeling angered and you're
off schedule oh it's 11 o'clock and
usually check your emails and judge
everybody well the body's looking for
that that predictable chemical state
every time you become aware that you're
doing that and your body is craving
those emotions
and you settle it back down into the
present moment you're telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind and now your will
is getting greater than the program and
if you keep doing this over and over
again over and over again over and over
again just like training a stallion
or a dog it's just gonna say
i'm gonna sit and the moment that
happens when the body is no longer the
mind when it finally surrenders
there's a liberation of energy
we go from particle to wave from matter
to energy and we free ourselves from the
chains of those emotions that keep us in
the in the familiar past and we've seen
this
thousands of times in fact we can
actually predict it now on a brain scan
when we talk about how do we create
rituals or how do we change habits
that last
the first thing is to have a different
expectation
than
i'm going to change in a day or a week
or in 21 days
whenever i try to change anything
my number one rule is 100 days
or i don't even start
so if i want to
let's say stop caffeine
it's a 100-day commitment
so first i make longer term commitments
and then i design a plan
to retrain my brain
around the expectation
of following through i make
pre-commitments
in advance so if i say let's say i'm
going to stop drinking coffee yeah
i say okay i'm going to stop drinking
coffee i commit to it for 100 days
and then i write out well what will you
do
in the morning when you wake up and you
want a coffee
what will you do when you're at a
restaurant with friends and everybody's
having a coffee what will you do so you
counter
any of the behavior
when you know the trigger is going to
happen
every habit has three parts to it
there's something that triggers the the
the emotion
there's the behavior and then there's
the neurological biological reward
so when you understand the habit part of
any ritual you understand that because
we are conditioned a certain way
we're going to have a trigger whether
it's a flower whether it's waking up
whether it's a girl or a guy or or
children coming home it triggers
a response in the brain or reaction in
the brain well if we change the behavior
over the course of 100 days
we'll still get the reward
and if we pre-commit to what we're going
to do when we say uh maybe today i'll
have the coffee and tomorrow i won't
maybe today i'll have the pizza or the
dessert and i'll catch up tomorrow
well if you pre-commit in advance
that you're not going to take that
action
then that's step one step two is
when you have the trigger if you
interrupt the behavior
for one or two or three or four minutes
you interrupt the neural pattern in the
brain also
so you come up with strategies when i
feel like having a coffee or dessert or
the pizza or
the croissant
okay
then here's what i'm going to do instead
for five minutes
and that way i can interrupt the pattern
if you do that long enough
you'll start to develop a new neural
pattern you'll start to develop a new
behavior and if you do it for at least
you know 66 days but preferably a
hundred days you'll start to develop a
new way of thinking and being and doing
that will overshadow
the other pattern in the brain very
interesting yeah so there's there's a
there's a
psychology behind it but there's also
the neurological processes of the brain
and what happens
is
our brain doesn't like change yeah so
any time that there is change the brain
see it feels uncomfortable as soon as it
feels uncomfortable it'll send signals
to the motor cortex of the brain it'll
send
messages and we'll start to rationalize
we'll start to tell ourselves well i
shouldn't do it because of this well
maybe today's not a good day we'll i'll
start today you know but i won't
continue until next week or you know
what i really don't want this we start
to talk to ourselves
and when we understand
what the brain does whenever we try to
change
then we can start being in control
of the brain and we can override the
automatic responses there's something
called automaticity
and automaticity
states that anything that i repeat over
and over and over again over a period of
time will go from
conscious effort
deliberate conscious effort will power
or persistence and it'll become
automatic
so we just have to know how long that is
and some things take a week
some things take 60 days
some habits that people have for 20 30
40 50 years take
200 days
and so you start off with a 100 day
window and you ask yourself am i willing
to give
a little bit of effort for 100 days to
remove this destructive either thought
pattern or destructive behavioral
pattern in order for me to have
something greater and better
than what i have right now
so it's very important you you focus a
lot on what you will have or what you
who you will are who you will be
in the future to keep
your motivation yeah if you think about
this one of the best
examples that i ever came up with
is imagine if
i give you
a hollywood script right now okay
and i say to you
if you learn this script
for the next six months
i will give you 10 million dollars
to be on stage to deliver that we're
gonna film you
and if you're amazing
you're gonna have a chance to win an
academy award
what will you do with the script
starting today
i start to learn start to learn you
start to read it you start to
emotionalize it you start to practice it
you start to you start to do everything
possible to become
something that's in writing
something that came out of somebody's
head
that they wrote a script for that you
don't have any idea what it is but if
you made a commitment
to becoming that person and you
rehearsed it and practiced it every day
you wouldn't get it right the first day
or the first week
for the first month or the first month
but if you knew there was a big payday
emotionally spiritually financially and
that people would go to the theaters and
love to watch it and they'd laugh or cry
or be sad and be happy because you were
able to take them on a beautiful
emotional rollercoaster ride
then you would become that role yeah
most people
are interested
they're not committed
and the difference is when you're
interested you do what's convenient and
what's easy but when you're committed
you do whatever it takes
[Music]
can you repeat it sure
when you're interested
you do what's easy and what's convenient
for you yeah but when you're committed
i'm gonna get that result
you put everything into it until you get
the result our identity should start
with unlearning
everything that we think we know about
ourselves okay how do we unlearn so the
best method of unlearning is this first
and i'm going to get really strategic
and tactical because i think that people
need to know what to do rather than a
concept the first thing you do is write
down everything you currently are
chasing in your life make a lot of goals
your dreams your goals your dreams
anything that you're currently chasing
and pursuing okay write them down you
can write down three equal and five you
can write down 10 depending on how
ambitious you are second line
ask yourself what is the source of that
where did you get that idea did you get
that idea from a tv show you saw did you
get that idea from your parents did you
get that idea from your mom and your dad
your sister your cousin did you get that
idea because your friend just got
proposed to on instagram did you get
that idea because your friend just got
promoted did you get that idea because
you just broke up right or did you get
that idea because you just feel it when
you do it that you feel alive just give
me a specific example that you had when
you were 15 18 was like a goal or
accomplishment that you were chasing and
where it came from absolutely so my my
goal when i was young was to be an
investment banker
and when i really asked myself where did
that come from it came because in my
community small community in london the
most successful person financially was
an investment banker so i believed you
had to be an investment banker to be
successful right so when i ask myself
that question where does that come from
it comes from society's version of
success not mine
and then the third thing you ask
yourself is well then what is mine what
is coming from inside of me and if you
just do that three-step process now what
you're doing is you're filtering out the
noise and you're starting to listen to
your voice the thing is you've got a
voice inside of you but it's quiet it's
like it's like jay like take note of me
like lewis you know and it's just like
trying to get through and the noise of
everyone else's opinions is so loud so
this way you filter it i need my story
all the things that my i've been telling
myself in my mind about myself and other
people and my parents
and my relatives and my co-workers and
my ex-wife and my ex-husband
and what people did to me and on what or
what i did and shouldn't have done
failed to do
who am i without the i can't let go of
that i need to think about this more
so it becomes a habitual place the
habitual place of the of
the mental noise where you feel that's
me
and so as every therapist knows
that you always reach a point where
there are
clients patients whatever depending on
the school of therapy depends whatever
you call the your clients your patients
whatever
there comes a point when you hit that
resistance
they don't want to be free of their
problems
and that the big challenge is there
is this person going to overcome
that barrier
because that barrier is not just
becoming free of my problems
but also
becoming free of a very
limited
and ultimately fictitious sense of
identity
the me
so that is
what i've
described is
the next
step one could say in the evolution of
human consciousness
is
stepping out of
self-talk which is
the conditioned mind
and realizing there is much more
to who i am
than this conditioned content of my mind
and that
is the beginning of awakening it's not
it's not those words not not that you
need to believe that there is much more
to who i am than the self-talk in my
head because that is still
self-talk in the head
i believe there's more to who i am
and you better believe it too
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to manifest
your success featuring les brown check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there it's not easy
it's hard changing your life
it was hard when just
over three years ago
in the penobscot building in detroit
michigan